or call 1-877-866-8555.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: IT IS THE GUT FAILED
RULE IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANYTHING WORSE AT THE MEDIA.
THE ONE THING WE NOW KNOW FOR
CERTAIN IS THAT POLITICS IS
SUPERSEDING MEDICINE HERE.
>> I WATCH THE CAR IN THE PARADE
AND HIM IN THE CAR, THAT WAS OUT
OF A DICTATOR’S PLAYBOOK.
>> IT IS A KARMA TO US BECAUSE
TRUMP HAS THE DEPLOYED SICKNESS
IN THIS CAMPAIGN.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT SEEMS
TO BE FLIRTING WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS BY NOT WEARING A MAS
GOING TO BIG RALLIES.
>> I WOULD NEVER SAY THE
PRESIDENT IS EXPERIENCING
PSYCHOSIS, BUT IT IS CERTAINLY
CONCERNING TO SEE HIS ACTIONS
TODAY.
>> HIS REACTION HAS BEEN
HOMICIDAL NEGLIGENCE.
HE HAS FAILED TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> WORSE THAN WATERGATE?
>> Greg: THE PRESIDENT GETS
SICK AND THEY SAY "I TOLD YOU
SO."
CNN IS THE WET MARKET ON THAT.
THEY HARDLY SAID ANYTHING EARLY
ON TOO BUSY GORGING ON
IMPEACHMENT BUT NOW THE
QUARTERBACK OF WISDOM IS KNOWING
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER IT HAPPENED.
OH, STEROID VIEWS PSYCHOSIS, YOU
ADMITTED HE NEVER HAD PSYCHOSIS
TO BEGIN WITH?
HOW NICE OF YOU.
THE FACT WAS EVERYONE WAS VIRUS
ABOUT THE VIRUS EVEN THE
EXPERTS, THE MEASURE OF THE
LEADER IS TO LISTEN TO ADVICE
AND TO WHAT IS RIGHT.
TRUMP ACTUALLY SENT A VOTE TO
NYC.
AND HE SENT TONS OF VENTILATORS
TO NYC, MONEY TO EVERYONE AND
THEY SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY.
HE STOPPED TRAVEL WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS CALLED HIM RACIST.
HE STAYED CALM WHEN OTHERS
WOULDN’T.
HE KNEW AS A LEADER HE MUST
ENDURE RISK TO EXPECT RISK FROM
OTHERS, YOU GO TO WORK AND SO
MUST HE.
WHY DO YOU THINK "THE FIVE" CAME
BACK TO THE STUDIO?
WE SAID IF HE GOES BACK TO WORK,
WE SHOULD TOO.
WHILE THE MEDIA MINDS FOR MISERY
ENCOURAGE COMPASSION.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A PEERLESS
BOMBASTIC PERSONALITY HAS A
HEALTH SCARE?
WILL HE CHANGE?
OF COURSE, TRUMP MIGHT BE TRUMP
FOREVER, BUT THE SCARY THING FOR
NEVER TRUMPERS IS A HEALTHY
TRUMP IN A COUNTRY THAT PREFERS
IT.
STILL HEALTH SHOCK CAN CHANGE
PEOPLE FOR GOOD.
LOOK AT ME.
I WENT THROUGH CHILDBIRTH AT AN
EARLY AGE, AND I HAVEN’T BEEN
THE SAME SINCE.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA, SO THEY SOUNDED THE ALARM,
THE MEDIA SOUNDS THE ALARM THAT
IT’S WAY WORSE THAN FRIDAY.
AND NOW, HE MUST BE A MURDERER.
HE’S OUT AND ABOUT TO BECOME A
MURDERER.
>> Dana: NO DOUBT THE
WHITE HOUSE DID NOT HAVE AN
INITIAL COMMUNICATIONS ROLLOUT
ON THIS ON SATURDAY.
AND I THINK THE PRESS OFFICE DID
AS BEST AS THEY COULD, BUT IF
THEY WILL BE CUT OUT OF THE
LOOP, YOU CANNOT EXPECT THEM TO
DO THAT AND A REAL DISSERVICE TO
KAYLEIGH McENANY AND HER TEAM.
SHE DESERVES BETTER AND THEY
DEMAND BETTER THAN THE
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF AND STAFF.
THAT WAS NO GOOD.
>> Greg: NO GOOD?
>> Dana: NOT GETTING COMPLETE
INFORMATION DOES NOT MEAN THAT
YOU CAN SPECULATE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S HEALTH.
IT DOESN’T WORK THAT WAY.
>> Dagen: I KNOW THE
PRESIDENT’S DOCTOR IS SAYING
THIS BUT MY AUNT POSTED
SOMETHING ON WMC AND THAT IS
SOMETHING WE CAN TAKE SERIOUSLY
GOING FORWARD.
SO WATCHING THAT MONTAGE COME I
CAN SEE WHY PEOPLE WATCH FOX ALL
DAY LONG.
>> Greg: WE ARE REAL.
I IMAGINE LIKE CNN, THE MORNING
BOARD MEETINGS AND GAUGES WHAT
IS THE MOST BIZARRE, DERANGED
THEORY AND WHEN THAT GOES IN THE
RED ZONE, THEY GO WITH THAT IN
THE LINEUP, PSYCHOSIS.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE A LOT OF
SCANDALS AND CONSPIRACIES OVER
THE WEEKEND, GREG.
I HAD BODY DOUBLES, WE WERE TOLD
THAT SAID STAGED PHOTO OPS.
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE OFFERS WITH
WALTER REED ON THE PRESIDENT.
WE HEARD ABOUT SECRET SERVICE
GATE.
AFTER THE MEDIA WATCHED VIDEO OF
COVID CROWDS SCREAMING IN THE
FACES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ALL SUMMER, ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY CARED ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DRIVING THE CAR
WITH ALL OF THE PPE AND MASKS.
THE GUYS HAD PROBABLY ALREADY
GOTTEN COVID AND VOLUNTEERED
WHICH WERE THE REPORTS.
I DON’T KNOW, GREG, THE
PRESIDENT IS INVINCIBLE THE WAY
THE MEDIA SET EXPECTATIONS SO
LOW.
THIS THING WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
DEATH SENTENCE AND HE’S WALKING
OUT OF WALTER REED THREE
DAYS LATER BETTER THAN EVER.
I JUST DON’T THINK THEY PLAYED
THIS RIGHT.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JUAN?
>> Juan: WALKING OUT OF WALTER
REED BETTER THAN EVER.
LOOK, I JUST WISH THE BEST FOR
HIM, BUT I’VE GOT TO SAY,
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING HIS OWN
DOCTOR SAID, YOU HAVE TO KEEP AN
EYE ON HIM.
GOING BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE
WHERE THEY GOT TREMENDOUS
MEDICAL -- IT’S NOT LIKE YOU AND
ME GOING HOME.
>> Jesse: UNDER THE COVERAGE,
THEY LOOK LIKE CHRIS KEEPERS.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK SO.
YOU HAVE A SITUATION IN GREG,
THIS SPEAKS, WHAT ABOUT,
SOMEBODY MADE A MISTAKE ONCE SO
HE MADE A MISTAKE AND HE’S
TRYING TO BE OPTIMISTIC.
THE REALITY IS HE DOWNPLAYED
THIS VIRUS ALL ALONG BY HIS OWN
ADMISSION.
THAT IS NOT ME SPEAKING.
THAT IS HIM ON TAPE SAYING I’M
GOING TO DOWNPLAY THIS.
OKAY, HE THEN DOWNPLAYS IT AND
DOESN’T FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
HE KNOWS SCIENCE SAYS THIS.
>> Greg: HE FOLLOWED THE
ADVICE OF THE EXPERTS.
>> Juan: OBVIOUSLY HE DID NOT.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU KNOW?
>> Juan: HE MOCKS JOE BIDEN,
LOOK AT THAT BIG MAN, HE MOCKS
THIS GUY AND I CAN COME AT THE
EXAMPLE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IS THE MASK IS POLITICAL.
IT IS NOT A MATTER OF SCIENCE,
NOT A MATTER OF BEST PROTECTION
AND IF TRUMP SUPPORTER DON’T
WEAR A MASK.
THAT IS OBSERVED.
THE THING ABOUT IT IS, HE DIDN’T
PROTECT US, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND HE DID NOT PROTECT HIS
STAFF.
YOU SHOULD HAVE HEARD MY PHONE,
SECRET SERVICE PEOPLE OVER THE
WEEKEND, BIZARRE, GONE OFF.
BUT HE IS PUTTING THEM AT RISK!
SO THAT HE CAN HAVE A --
>> Greg: THEY CALLED YOU?
>> Juan: NOT ONLY THAT, WHEN
YOU STOP AND THINK ABOUT THE
ABSOLUTE NUMBERS, YOU KNOW, 4%
OF THE WORLD POPULATION HERE IN
AMERICA, 25% OF THE CORONAVIRUS
CASES HERE, THAT HIS FAILURE.
THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE FAILURE.
>> Greg: I HAVEN’T FOUND THE
MATH.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO HOLD ON
AND SAY, WAIT A SECOND.
I HOPE THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
APPEARANCES AND SPIN.
I HOPE HE IS OKAY.
>> Jesse: YOU DON’T SOUND LIKE
YOU HOPE HE’S OKAY.
>> Juan: BUT IT’S LIKE WHAT
JOHN BOLTON SAID, EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT HIS REELECTION.
>> Dagen: YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
SAID FOR YEARS, HE IS A DICTATOR
AND HE WANTS TO POWER GRAB.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID, HE NOT ACT
LIKE A DICTATOR.
HE GAVE THE POWER TO THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE LOCAL DECISIONS
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT REGIONS OF
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTANDS WE ARE A NATION OF
GREAT LIBERTIES AND FREEDOMS.
AMERICANS DON’T LIKE BEING TOLD
WHAT TO DO.
SO YOU LEAVE IT UP TO PEOPLE.
WEAR A MASK, BUT I’M NOT GOING
TO MANDATE IT.
OKAY, JOE BIDEN.
REALLY QUICKLY IN TERMS OF THE
PROFESSIONAL PANICKED PADDLERS
AND THE MEDIA.
THESE PEOPLE, SOME OF THEM
CLEARLY OVER THE WEEKEND STOOD
BACK AND SAID, I’VE ONLY GOT A
TEASPOON OF CREDIBILITY LEFT.
IF ONLY GOT LIKE A SCOOP OF
INTEGRITY BUT I’M FLUSHING IT
ALL AWAY NOW.
I WILL LEAVE THIS JOB AND GO
SELL KANSAS SEEDS AND BOMB
SHELTERS FOR THE NEXT
APOCALYPSE.
I EXPECT SOME OF THEM THEY ARE
SO -- EXPLETIVE TO BE STANDING